It's important for us to know what's real
in the world and if we're going to be making
decisions about our own lives or about healthcare
policy, environmental policy, what to eat,
what to do in terms of medications, we need
to know what reality is – that way we're
not constantly smacking ourselves up against
it.
It is true, certainly in politics, that it
can be very difficult to get people to agree
on basic facts, but I think it is possible
in some circumstances to basically turn to
scholars and experts in fields and ask them
to try to help adjudicate what is real and
what is false.
And increasingly, because of the polarization
within politics, there are more and more think
tanks that are on both the right and the left
that are actually very serious about facts
because they're worried about this kind of
denigration into a situation where everybody
just believes what they want to believe.
I think we're about to see a big corrective.
I mean the fact that you're even asking these
questions suggests to me that we're seeing
a corrective where people are interested in
trying to get closer to reality.
And I actually see that on the right as well,
within scholarship that is right of center,
within foundations that are right of center.
There certainly are some on both extremes
that are interested just yelling their idea,
whether or not it's real, there are various
people who come to mind, but there's more
and more interest in trying to do the corrective
and trying to understand what's serious and
real.
We see this, for example, with conservatives
becoming very concerned around climate change.
We see this I think on the left with regard
to people who have historically said patients
should have full autonomy, beginning to think
about well what does that mean when patients
have false knowledge when, for example, they
think the measles vaccine is very dangerous
when science suggests that it is not very
dangerous?
When they think that doing placenta treatments
on their skin is somehow important and safe
and scientific when it's really not.
So I think that corrective is helping.
How do we as individuals understand what is
true?
It is really hard.
There is so much noise and there is so many
things that look convincing that are not convincing.
That's a relatively new thing in history to
have the level at which people are able to
produce things that look real and high level,
high quality, high scholarly levels that are
not real is kind of terrifying.
So there are fake journals that look real,
there are fake news stories, as we know, that
appear to be real and it becomes increasingly
difficult to understand what is real.
For the average person, it's very hard to
know what to trust, but there are some trusted
places like, for example, Wikipedia, Snopes,
various places that do fact checking.
There are various newspapers that do fact
checking as well, factcheck.org for example
is another place.
But then in order for those places to survive
it's really clear that people have to financially
support them so that people can do that work
and it's hard to convince people to support
nonpartisan fact checking work because people
have been taught to favor, with their clicks
and their dollars and their like buttons,
to favor opinion that they agree with.
It's very rare for people comparatively to
forward actual articles compared to forwarding
opinion pieces.
So what we see is that the kinds of things
that come under your nose because your friends
are sharing it or your colleagues are sharing
it is much more often opinion than facts.
We don't have the idea that we should stick
a like on something that's just factual, forward
it to a friend if it's simply factual.
We want the opinion analysis of it that agrees
with our opinion of what the facts mean and
that's the thing we forward.
And I don't know how to solve that problem
other than to say if people with money don't
start supporting fact-checking systems then
fact-checking systems will become increasingly
rarer.
So the newspaper I run in East Lansing does
political fact checking.
When the mailers come out for the latest local
campaign, whether that's for city council
or for school board or for various tax proposals
we take the mailers and we do fact checking.
This is not a novel concept, newspapers have
been doing this for years, but it's increasingly
unusual for mainstream newspapers to take
the time to do that kind of fact checking,
especially on the candidates they're endorsing.
It's one reason we don't endorse candidates
at my newspaper because we believe very firmly
that that's not our job.
Our job is not to tell people what to think,
our job is to bring forward what we know.
And, in the past, newspapers had more of a
commitment to that, but that's not where the
money is.
When people subscribe to newspapers they do
it not for the information, they do it often
because of the opinion pages, because of the
op-ed pages, because of the editorials.
So newspapers are stuck in the position where
that's what they have to do in order to support
the news side of the organization.